[Music]
welcome back so I'm really excited in
this lecture to tell you about something
called the Gabor transform which is used
to compute the spectrogram so this is
part of our section on the Fourier
transform so essentially we're used to
thinking about the Fourier transform as
taking some signal either in space or in
time and writing it in terms of its
frequency components okay so for example
I can take a audio signal and I can
Fourier transform it and I can pull out
what are the kind of individual
frequency components that that add up to
make that audio signal okay and I'm just
gonna draw some pictures here so imagine
I have some time series data I've got
some you know maybe this is an audio
recording of you know I have a
microphone in some Symphony Hall and I'm
listening to you know someone play a
piano okay and what I can do is I can
Fourier transform this signal and in the
frequency domain now so now this is a
function of some frequency with units of
Hertz the side units of seconds maybe I
can see spikes Fourier spikes in the
power spectrum corresponding to
individual tones on on that piano so
maybe each individual key will come as a
spike in this frequency with with power
determined by how much kind of that that
key was played in that song okay but
this gets to the heart of the
spectrogram and the Gabor transform is
this idea that if I look at my signal as
a function of time
I have precision information about where
in time I am but I don't know what the
frequency is at that instant in time
okay it could be it's some combination
of frequencies similarly when I Fourier
transform I have exquisite information
about exactly what frequencies were
played in that song but I don't know
when you know maybe this is the
see you know key or you know a low C or
something
I know exactly what frequencies were
played but I don't know when they were
played in the song that's a big problem
so in time domain I know where my signal
is in time but I don't know anything
about the instantaneous frequencies here
I know everything about what frequencies
were played but I don't know where they
occurred in time this is what the Gabor
transform is going to allow us to figure
out
so the Gabor transform the Gabor
transform is going to allow us to
compute something called the spectrogram
the spectrogram which essentially is a
time frequency plot of what frequencies
are active in specific instances in time
so it's kind of a map evolving in time
of what frequencies are being played I
always think about this in terms of you
know the piano or a guitar music right
so the music has frequencies that are
that are evolving in time and the
skateboard transform is going to allow
us to pull out both the frequency
content and the temporal information of
that signal okay and this is really
really important is this idea that the
Fourier transform really makes sense for
signals that are perfectly periodic
something that is completely periodic
and repeating and audio signals are not
like that they have frequency content
but one second of audio is rarely going
to be periodically repeated in the
second the third the fourth the fifth
seconds so someone's voice speaking or
someone playing you know a symphony or
some song on a piano
it has frequency components at each
instant in time but they're not periodic
in time okay and so so this is what the
the Gabor transform is going to give us
and so what we do in the Gabor transform
is instead of computing the Fourier
transform over the entire temporal
domain what we do is we take a little
Gaussian window some some fixed width
window and we convolve our Fourier
transform with this little Gaussian
window sliding across our signal
basically we are computing a waited for
you transform only in this window and
removing that window across we're
sliding that window across the signal in
time and so the result of this Gabor
transform is we will have a time
frequency plot okay so we'll have some
resolution in time and we'll have some
resolution in frequency and so for
example if I take this first Gabor
window I basically compute the Fourier
transform of this little section of my
data and I get some you know maybe these
keys are being hit on the piano and then
as I slide this forward in time now
maybe there's different frequency
content in the next instant maybe now
there's some different frequency content
these keys are being played and so on
and so forth as this evolves in time you
see this kind of different pattern of
frequencies that are evolving in time
okay so each vertical strip of this
spectrogram so this is my spectrogram
and each vertical strip is basically a
power spectrum for a little short window
of time and I have this moving window
this is sliding across giving me a
sliding power spectrum of what
frequencies are being played as time
evolves so this is really useful this
tells me not just what frequencies are
active in my in my system but when they
occurred okay so it's somehow kind of
the hybrid between these two pictures we
have some temporal resolution and some
frequency resolution now you can't have
as much frequency resolution or as much
time resolution in this spectrogram and
so there's always a trade-off based on
how wide this window is kind of how much
resolution you have in time or in
frequency okay but this can be pretty
useful so for example you know if I if I
make some noise I start with a low
frequency mm and then I increase the
frequency
mmm you can see kind of that that
temporal evolution of that frequency
going from low to high in time okay and
that's really really cool and you can
only get that using this kind of Gabor
transform which which gives rise to the
spectrogram okay now mathematically this
is actually really really simple it's
basically built on the Fourier transform
so you can use the fast Fourier
transform to compute this and what you
do is if you had some signal F let's
call this F of T then your Gabor
transform of F is going to be this
function f hat sub G this is just
telling us it's a good Bohr transform
and it's going to be a function about
time and frequency so unlike the Fourier
transform this is going to be a function
of time and frequency so it's a you know
kind of a dual function and it's going
to be given by basically the Fourier
transform so integral from negative
infinity to infinity of f of tau e to
the minus I Omega tau but now I'm going
to multiply it by this little Gaussian
Gabor window here this little Gaussian
function G of tau I'm gonna multiply it
by G of t minus tau D tau okay so this
Gabor transform of F is basically just
the Fourier transform of F but weighted
by this little Gaussian window that's
sliding across okay so I get something
that's a function of frequency because
I'm Fourier transforming but that is in
this sliding window that's pinned to
this particular time T so now I have
something that's a function of both
Omega and T in this in the spectrogram
okay so this is the Gabor transform it's
just a Fourier transform weighted by
this little Gaussian that is sliding
across in time and so it gives you some
resolution of what frequencies are
active but it also gives you some
resolution of when those frequencies are
active in time so it's this kind of this
time frequency diagram very very useful
Gabor transform and spectrogram
okay so I think this is an extremely
powerful method for analyzing data
okay so oftentimes when you get a time
series of data maybe I put my phone on
the hood of my car and I'm listening to
it do its thing you can use the
spectrogram to pull out features in that
data so I have colleagues who use the
spectrogram to classify sounds in the
ocean okay so there they're doing
measurements in the ocean and on a boat
and they want to tell if someone you
know dropped a chain on the boat or if
some you know a whale just swam by or if
you know if something is happening it
usually shows itself as some kind of
evolving frequency signature in time in
the spectrogram so oftentimes when you
want to classify audio signals you want
to take your signal and not just
transform to the Fourier series or the
Fourier domain you want to transform to
this spectrogram domain this is this
Gabor transform okay
this is how is am can classify music so
for example if you are listening to a
song and you want to know what it is you
hold your phone up with Shazam what it
does is it basically finds peaks in the
power spectrum and it tries to match
this kind of sparse template of peaks to
a library of known songs and this is
kind of interesting I didn't know this
until until recently when you listen to
songs on the radio they can stretch them
out or shrink them by you know maybe 10%
faster or slower and the human ear has a
hard time recognizing you know those
those small changes speed ups and slow
downs but the radio stations will
stretch out the song or shrink them to
fit a slot between the the commercial
breaks and so that makes it a little bit
harder for the shows an algorithm to
match these Peaks and they have to do
something a little bit more clever
figuring out if I slowed my song down or
sped it up how would this spectrogram
scale you know in time and frequency so
that's kind of an interesting problem
that the Shazam out or them uses okay
you can also for example classify you
know if I have some song being played I
can
so classify was it played on a guitar or
a piano was it played on an electric
guitar or an acoustic guitar because you
know these individual notes being played
might look different they might you know
have a little bit of a trill or some
signature of what instrument they were
played on or even who played those notes
so I would pose to you that if you
wanted to for example classify you know
different musicians so you want to see
if it was Jimi Hendrix playing this song
you might be able to do that by pulling
features out of this spectrogram okay
that's pretty interesting and so I'm
going to show you how to code this up
soon we're gonna look at some examples
of how to do a chirp how to do the
spectrogram of an audio signal but I'm
gonna pull up one of my favorite videos
this is actually a YouTube video from
from Jan Kay so I hope it's okay to to
show this I think this is a great video
that they made it's one of my favorites
this is a spectrogram of Beethoven's
sonata and you can just see it playing
here I'm going to hit play I'm gonna
turn my volume up so you can see the
slider moving across the screen and you
can see that every note is one of these
dark black kind of signatures in this in
the spectrogram plot
so it's really neat you can actually
kind of see when the keys are being
played how they're being played you can
tell when it's going to get more active
or less active and you know I think it's
also interesting I always joke with my
class you know Beethoven didn't have
fifty fingers these are kind of
harmonics that are being generated in
the piano from these chords and so you
can see all of that rich rich structure
in this in the spectrogram okay good so
in the next couple of lectures I'm going
to code this up we're going to actually
work with the spectrogram and look at
this this time frequency diagram for a
few different audio signals okay thank
you